Hello. I'm Briana, and in this video,
I'm gonna go over a lot of things having to do with Bash,
mostly the basics.
We're going to start off really basic, like, what is Bash?
What is that, you know--how do I even get around?
All the way through configuration, using different types of scripts with Bash.
So hopefully at the end, you'll feel a bit more comfortable working in the terminal,
So starting off: as you can see, Bash is a terminal.
It is the terminal used on Mac and Linux by default,
so it's a little bit different than PowerShell.
When people say terminal, it could mean a lot of different things.
It could mean Bash.
It could mean something like zsh shell, which is kind of similar,
or PowerShell, but this is all about Bash.
So we open up Bash.
I opened up my terminal application on my Mac computer,
and the very first thing that I want to type--
so it's kind of intimidating if you've never been here before--
but I want to just do "echo $0",
so echo space dollar sign zero.
This--I click enter, return.
This says Bash,
So this is just confirming that I am in Bash.
So find your terminal, type "echo $0".
If it says Bash, then you're in the right spot.
Whatever I type today should work for you as well
unless you have some different configuration setup.
So we're here.
We don't know what "here" is other than Bash,
so I'm going to type pwd.
So pwd stands for Print Working Directory.
And that just means it's going to print out wherever I currently am.
So currently, I'm in my computer's users directory and then githubteacher.
So that's the user that I'm logged into right now.
I can use pwd at any time to know where I am,
which is pretty helpful.
The next command I want to show is called ls.
So ls is going to list whatever's in my current directory,
if there's any files or other directories.
So here, I see I've got locations, documents, library.
What you'd expect.
We also have ls space dash al.
Let's see if there's any hidden files here.
And it also gives us some more information.
We see all these letters on the left. We'll talk about those later.
Owner of the file, their permission level,
and then here the dot in front of a file means it's a hidden file,
so when I just did ls,
I wasn't able to see those files like .trash, .atom, .bash_history, which we'll talk about soon.
So know that ls and ls -al are there
so that you can see what's going on in the directory that you're currently in.
When I list my files and directories,
I see documents, downloads, all these things.
I want to make a new folder, a new directory called Projects,
so I'm gonna do mkdir for make directory
and then space and then Projects.
I'll do a capital P here.
So I type "mkdir Projects", hit enter.
It tells me nothing,
But if I do ls...
I can see, now I have...
a Projects directory that I didn't have before.
So I just created an empty file, that's it...
using mkdir.
So I've made this directory, but I'm not currently in it.
So, right, if I do pwd, I'm still in my githubteacher directory.
So to change directories,
I'll do "cd Projects".
cd space Projects
What you see on the left-hand side changes a little bit.
That'll depend on what configurations,
what, you know...
That can look different from computer to computer,
especially with developers that have been using Bash for a while.
If I do pwd now...
It's a little different.
So before, I was just in githubteacher;
now, I'm in githubteacher/Projects.
So I created the directory and then changed directory into it.
If I do ls here,
we see nothing.
ls -al.
I just see these dots, which means I can go back.
So we've changed directory into a directory,
but, like, maybe I want to go back.
Let's say I want to go back to being in this githubteacher directory.
I can type--
Come back, terminal.
I'll type cd space dot dot.
Now if I do pwd,
I'm back in githubteacher.
No big deal.
We've created a directory.
It's good to know how to get rid of a directory just in case.
So if you need to delete a directory,
you can do rmdir.
So mkdir to create.
"rmdir", and then I'll do Projects.
The one I just created, I'm just going to scrap it.
Now if I do ls--oops not ld.
If I do ls...
then Projects is no longer there.
Even if I do ls -al, it's not there anymore.
I'll go ahead and recreate that.
"mkdir Projects" just so that we have something to--
we're going to keep making some changes.
But now you've seen a lot of the basics.
We know how to navigate around.
We know where we are with pwd.
We can change directories with cd,
both forwards and backwards;
list the files in any given directory; make directories; delete directories.
It's already a lot, right, with just a few really basic commands.
Hopefully by now,
you already are figuring out there's nothing to be afraid of
when you're in the terminal.
Let's talk a little bit about working with files.
We've talked about directories; let's work with files.
All files are case-sensitive with Bash.
This is important to consider, as you might be working with something--
another program, like, maybe you're working with Git.
and the way Git or any program handles case sensitivity
might be different than how Bash handles case sensitivity,
So keep in mind: Bash is case-sensitive.
Let's cd into that Projects--change directories into Projects.
And I'm gonna make a new file.
Because we do ls, we see there's nothing.
To create a new empty file,
I'm just going to type touch--
I'll call it file1.md
for markdown, the file format that I use a lot.
Press return. Tells me nothing.
If I do ls,
now I see I have this file1.md.
If I do ls -al,
I've still got those dot files.
We have file1.md.
See who it's owned by,
and the letters are a little different, but we'll get there.
Creating a file, pretty easy.
To delete that file, rm--
just "rm file1.md".
Now it's no longer there.
Some different ways we can manipulate files.
Let's go ahead and make this file again.
We'll call it file2.md.
I've created this file.
Let's say I want to copy this file,
so I want to make a duplicate.
I'm going to type "cp file2.md"
and then the name that I want the new copy to have.
So I'm going to call this file2-copy.md.
As soon as I do that, if I do ls,
I see I've got these two files here.
They're empty. They're both empty,
but if file2 had some contents in it,
that would now be mapped exactly to file2-copy.
You can also rename files just really simply.
So if I do mv...
Let's say, I want file2-copy, this new file,
I want that to just be called file3,
so I'll do mv file2-copy.md--the old name--
and then the new name.
I'm going to call file3.
If I do ls -al, file2-copy's now been renamed file3.
Pretty straightforward.
So far since we've started working with files,
we've used touch, rm, mv, and cp.
So touch creates a file,
rm removes it,
cp copies it and creates another one,
and mv just renames it--or moves it to a different file name.
We also have cat for concatenate.
Concatenate.
So this is a way to create single or multiple files.
You can view the contents of a file;
you can link files together,
so view multiple files;
redirect output in terminable files.
There's a lot you can do with cat.
Since these two files are empty right now,
let's put some--let's put some things in there.
So let's do that with VI.
So VI is kind of a different level.
So Bash and terminal can already be intimidating.
VI, I would say, is another level.
VI is always a text editor within the terminal.
You might hear people also--VIM.
VIM and VI are different.
I don't use either one regularly,
so I'm sure there are a lot of people out there
who can go into a lot more detail than I can,
but it's important to know a little bit about VI.
You might end up in VI by accident,
and it doesn't behave, necessarily, how you'd think.
So let's--let's use it.
To use VI, let's add some contents to file2.
So I'm gonna type "vi file2.md".
It's gonna open up file2 in VI.
So already it looks very different.
If I tried to just type anything, it might not work.
Once you're in VI mode, to actually insert,
you press i or j.
So there's two modes of VI:
there's insert and command.
So I'm going to type i--
I hit i on my keyboard,
and now we can see at the bottom, it says insert.
Now I'm able to type.
So I'm going to say:"File 2 is the best file in the entire directory!"
So I've made my changes.
Now what do I want to do, right?
How do I get out? If I press enter, it just goes down.
Getting--I think that's like--
"How do I get out of VI" is the most asked question on Stack Overflow.
So here we are. How do we get out of VI?
First, we need to get into that command mode, right?
So I'm going to press ESC.
We see the insert is gone at the bottom.
I'm going to shift so it's COLON,
And now we can see that at the bottom.
That's putting us into command mode.
"w" for write because I want to save these changes.
And "q" for quit.
I could just do q, and it wouldn't save,
but wq will save and quit.
Hit enter.
So that's it. I'm out of VI.
Let's do that again.
Let's do it for file3, so I'm going to open "vi file3.md".
First thing I do is...
type i to begin insert mode.
Start typing. "File 3 is a pretty good file too."
Now, my instinct as somebody who uses a computer
is to do CMD s or CTRL s to save,
but that will not work in VI the same way it will work in other programs.
To get out of this, I'm gonna hit ESC to get out of insert mode...
colon wq...
and enter. We're done.
So we've kind of done these basics of VI.
Just the need-to-know basics of how to get out,
and how to get in, how to make some changes.
Let's use that cat command.
So you're gonna do "cat file2.md",
and it prints out just the contents of file2
that I just put in there.
I can do "cat file2.md file3.md".
So I'm doing two different files, and it prints out both...
both of the contents. The contents for both of the files.
So, so far, we've done a lot, right?
We've worked with directories, how to get around.
If I do pwd, the first thing we really talked about--
I'm still in my Projects directory--
ls. I still have these two files here: file2 and file3.
Let's talk a little bit about how to configure your Bash shell.
So what that means is right now my Bash is pretty...
monotone.
There's just white and black. Um...
If you're ever--if you ever see somebody else working in a terminal,
whether it's on a video or in person, you know,
sitting next to somebody on an airplane,
their terminal might not look like this.
It probably doesn't look like this.
I configure mine to have some different colors
that make it easier for me to read,
which is some, you know--the most basic, probably, way to do it.
But you can configure your Bash terminal for a lot of different things.
So you can include aliases so that I--
you only have to type something small
but actually will run a much longer script or command.
You can configure authentication tokens
for different services like Git and GitHub.
Let's start out with the colors.
So for the colors...
The first thing we're gonna look for is this .bash_profile and .bashrc.
So again pwd. I'm in Projects.
I need to cd back into my main user directory.
And I'm going to do ls -al.
So I see I have...
bash _history and bash_sessions,
but since I haven't used the bashrc or bash_profile file yet,
they are not on this user--
They are not on this user account.
If those files exist or not by default will depend on your operating system.
So Linux, you probably already have those.
Mac, you might not.That's OK.
We're just going to create them.
So we know how to create files:
"touch .bashrc"
and "touch .bash_profile".
bash_profile is executed for login shells,
and bashrc is executed for interactive non login shells
meaning bash_profile is going to have those authentication tokens that we talked about;
whereas, bashrc is gonna have more just general...
general configurations in it.
Okay, so I'm gonna open up that bashrc.
I'm not gonna do it in VIM.
I'm actually going to use my favorite text editor, which is Atom.
And to do that, I'm gonna go to Atom...
There is a way to configure Atom, so it's a--
you just Atom space and the file name.
I haven't done that yet. Let's see if it'll work just by default.
Atom space dot. Oh, great. So Atom space...
anything will open up that specific file.
Dot in Bash, like I just did,
means current directory.
So this opened the current directory
so everything I see on the left-hand side here
is the same I would see in an ls -al.
I'm going to open up this bashrc file in Atom,
and I'm going to copy this--
which I'll put in the video description here--
here.
Nope, actually, no, I'm not.
I'm going to put that in the bash_profile.
So what this does is...
This is making sure that we only are sourcing the bashrc from the bash_profile.
If Bash doesn't know where to look,
it might not behave how you'd expect it to.
You might get some different errors and bugs.
So this is making sure that, um,
the bash_profile is always looking for the bashrc
to make sure it's taking whatever configurations are there into account also.
So I'll save that change in my bash_profile.
Now when I log into any machine from a console,
this bashrc is automatically going to be called.
Let's go ahead and configure some colors.
Let me pull up these...
different colors here.
This is what I'm looking at.
So I'll put a link to this little gist of code.
So it's a little bit different if--
depending on your operating system.
Since I'm on a Mac, I'm gonna add this to the bash_profile.
So here's this script.
So this is going to be affecting my Git output specifically.
So you could do that or this one here.
This is specifically for Git.
Copied one. I'll put that in bash_profile.
This--this hash sign I'm putting here is comment.
Colors for Git output.
And I'll paste that in and save.
And I also want to...
So this is something I got from a friend.
I'll save that, get rid of that,
and then back in the bashrc, let's write colors for other text.
Let's try this.
Now here, let's open up terminal again.
There we go. Okay, so...
CLICOLOR=1 enables coloring of your terminal,
and then the LSCOLORS specifies how to color specific items.
Okay.
There we go.
So there's a lot of different ways you can...
you know...
customize this so that the output is much different.
Here we do pwd. It's still black. ls- al.
Here we see how, you know,
certain things look different
based on if they're a directory or if they are just a file.
Customizing your prompt and configuring things
goes a lot deeper than this.
You could--what you can do is absolutely massive.
But the most important thing to know
is that you find those customizations in your .bashrc and your .bash_profile.
Okay. Let's move on to something else.
Let's talk about the internet.
So I'm gonna type clear here.
Clear is just a terminal--
a shell Bash command to literally clear off everything that's on the terminal
so that you have a fresh start. Clear. All right.
So you can interact with the internet and other networks from Bash.
That means, you know, whatever program you're using
can interact with the internet.
You'd usually want to do this to check the network connectivity or speed.
So if I type "ping google.com",
that tells me how fast my internet connection is really quickly.
I'm gonna press CTRL--hold it down and then click c to exit that.
So if you ever stuck in a mode--
it's either VI mode, right--
and then you would do escape colon wq
or something like this where there's an operation running--a system task--
then I would do CTRL + c to exit that.
So interacting with the internet:
a lot of different CLI tools will access the internet.
Git is a great example of this.
So I'd have my remote repository on github.com,
my local repository on my computer.
I can interact with that entirely from Bash,
and that will be done via the Internet.
So just remember anything that you do, um...
in the shell, right--
you are not automatically just on your own computer.
Which is a great thing, but also good to know in case you might be making changes to something?
Let's move on to: What else can you do from Bash?
so we've done quite a bit already, right?
We've created files. We've navigated around.
We know how to get out of V and get--
or get out of VI and get into VI.
Let's talk about how to do some more advanced things,
mostly scripts.
So as an example,
I would like to show you...
this script, and we're gonna create it, we're gonna run it, we're gonna make it work.
So this script here...
This example is what I use before I teach class--
that I was talking about.
It quits certain applications; it hides my dock.
Because I really don't want slack notifications coming up while I'm teaching a class.
And it opens certain applications.
So Mouspose and Moon,
which are things I use to show my mouse and move windows around.
Make sure those are open.
Make sure certain browsers are open.
And it even triggers other scripts like the teach-class script.
One that we're going to create is really simple.
So here we see the top line is:
this #!/bin/bash .
That just tells Bash that this file is actually a Bash script.
So I'm gonna go ahead and go back to Bash here.
I'm going to cd out of this repository,
so I'm back in Projects.
We can see that here.
I'm going to--
Let's take a look at this script.
Okay, so it's just a good-morning world.
So I'm going to touch good-morning.
So I just created a file called good-morning.
And I'm going to "vi good-morning",
so now I'm in VI, okay?
Next, let's insert.
IfI type i so that we're in insert mode.
And at the top it's that #!/bin/bash .
Enter. Clear.
We want to just clear the prompt, right?
Like you could do as any standalone command.
And echo,
which we haven't talked about yet.
"echo" just has the terminal--
has Bash print out exactly what's in quotes.
so echo "Good morning, world."
will then have the terminal print that out.
"echo" is a really, really useful command when you're working with shell scripts
because frequently through your scripts you might want to know,
you know, like a console log of kind of thing,
you know, what's going on.
I want to have this as feedback. This message will print out...
at a certain time during my script.
So that's good. Looks good.
I hit escape colon wq
and exit.
Now let's see the moment of truth.
We've created this script.
If I just type "good-morning",
let's see what--what we expect.
It says "command not found".
Let's talk a little bit about all these letters at the beginning.
So back in the terminal here,
if I do "ls- al" we see at the beginning of these files...
all these drwxr, you know, slash.
Those are impacting our ability to run that script out of the command.
So chmod and file folder permissions.
So this first blank indicates the file type,
whether it's a directory with a d or just a slash--it's a regular file.
From then, we have these three other groups:
one for the owner, members of the group, and all other users.
So that means any given file might have  different permissions
for other people on the computer.
You know, as an owner, I might be able to do something,
but then if somebody else logged into the machine,
they would only be able to, you know, read that file.
They couldn't execute whatever that script was.
So what you want to do--
if we take a look at our newly created script, which is called good-morning,
nowhere is it executable.
We have r, read access; w, write access for the owner,
so I'm allowed to make edits
No one else can make edits even.
But we want to have x.
I'm not so concerned of if other users have any access to this file.
I just want to have access right now.
So what I'm gonna do is type:
"chmod +x" and then the filename.
So if I do ls- al, now I see good-morning has...
this x next to it.
Now it's red because it's an executable script
Instead of just good-morning,
we're going to do dot, you know, period slash good-morning.
And it cleared the terminal and did "Good morning, world."
Earlier, it wasn't working because I was just typing "good-morning",
and remember when we're navigating throughout the terminal,
it is relative and it matters where we are.
So it didn't know exactly where to look for good-morning here,
but when we do dot slash,
meaning go back directory and look for the slash,
then good-morning--or current directory and slash,
then we're in good shape
Then it knows exactly where to look.
So obviously, this is a very simple script example,
but that's how easy it is.
Anything that you run in any command
can be put inside of a shell script,
whether it's basic shell, you know, language things
or API calls or other programs.
So a lot to know here.
There's a lot to--to be done.
And thank you.
Hopefully you feel better about using Bash.
Hopefully you feel like you can, um,
not be so afraid of using your terminal.